[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right we can't do a long intro we
can do long intro this is a special show
a way to sit down and pre record because
of Pacific time
Eastern Time Central all the time zones
all the time are actually be all matter
equally we're going to New York City
because we're among the few invited to
this private youtube concert I'm hoping
we get our Illuminati membership cards
so when we do this we want to sit down
and have a long talk this is by far our
most requested of anyone with this it'll
give you a longer chat with this man has
this show of course you hear him on
Salem radio every day you can follow him
on twitter at dennis prager
dennis prager compre our university
which we post about all the time what
what i would say i think it's because he
has a voice you can talk about anything
and you would find it immediately
interesting like sam a leroy yes yes
exactly
mr. Prager thank you for being here sir
well I I was thinking of reading the
phone book to you and yes testing that
thesis but they don't make phone books
anymore
now did you just did you develop this
through years of cigars and bourbon did
you just come out of the womb talking
like justice mr. Prager well I have a
few answers to that you'll love this
okay so I did not speak till I was three
and my grandfather may he rest in peace
thought I was [ __ ] so and my my line
is so people say white why didn't you
start speaking so late I said because I
wasn't getting paid yes
I couldn't charge I started speaking
when I could charge so so even little
three-year-old dennis prager was like
the joker if you're good for something
new you look for free I have a litlle
one here oh well yeah yeah now that you
mentioned if I was a capitalist that
they won I I used to sell to my
classmates stamps really yeah foreign
stamps I would put them in beautiful
glassine envelopes I would put a little
white sticker on it explain me what it
was I loved I loved it's not I don't
love money as it happens I'm not money
crazed at all right but I loved making
it
I loved creating something that others
wanted sure you know didn't you say that
stamps but I don't know that there was a
big market in your class for stamps
yes that you know what it's very sad to
me you want to do a show on this
okay the death of hobbies well there's
the new hobby now the hope enough to see
that having happened yeah well when I
was young it was pogs and I he remembers
pausing I don't remember this this was
remember the old milk caps they used to
have underneath milk and everything and
then they would have pictures so with my
generation they took that and they
turned it into a game where you would
stack up the pogs and you'd hit it with
what's called a slammer it was like
plastic sometimes it was heavier than
the pogs themselves and as many as you
turned over you would get to keep and I
remember at a Christmas recital as a kid
I went to my friend Johnny Prescott I
forgot to bring my pogs I said listen
give me five pogs
and a slammer you will get half of
everything that I procure this evening I
came back with 50 pogs I hustled at pogs
in the schoolyard so then they were
banned the next week so that goes to
your point any hobby that's fun the
school's band so is that little is that
a legit hobby that is that that's fun
but you know what I think of hobby so a
stamp collecting coin collecting for
example collect well that's that was a
collection and that that's true but it's
not one you would want to keep I don't
think where as you know stamps and coins
have a permanent interest that's
probably where until I learned an
immense amount as a child about the
world through stamp collecting I mean
did you ever hear of Lichtenstein unless
you collect stamps nobody ever heard of
Lichtenstein I'm not going to lie I
haven't exactly no no that's my whole
point I did neither so what but I have
another one of my hobbies is collecting
countries I've been to 130 countries wow
that's a lot of travel that is so I
remember when I went to Liechtenstein
holy grow I know about this place I have
there stamps
anyway it is so I'm justice for cards
did your generation collect any cards
well people did I wasn't as much in
distorted I collect a lot of a salon we
collected superhero cards and hockey
cards in Canada but it was past the
point where they really accrued in value
not like your generation you know where
some of those always a lot all right so
you're talking to a fellow hockey fan
even though I'm American really you know
you know that this was the first family
Cup playoff championship but both
coaches were American I didn't know that
that is actually that is remarkable
because you know my dad played it is
remarkable both American gosh when you
look at back of my dad played at U of M
and they basically only drafted Canadian
players and American players kind of had
to go through this sort of training camp
it wasn't even considered because all
the best players came from Canada it's
changed so much I mean you just look at
rice Dallas is a hotbed for hockey now
my dad well look at the biggest hotbed
Nashville that's real Tennessee I know
yeah I know Nashville Tennessee vote but
I will say this has internet you bring
it up and it transitions into what we I
wanted to talk about with you hobbies
you know I don't know if you would
consider not just collecting but you
know for example like martial arts or
certain like jogging if you consider
these hobbies or activities but there is
a big push right now you see that with
the rise of CrossFit and of course the
rise of injuries so orthopedics are
thrilled on the third place which we all
used to have right there as we talked
about that home Church there was the
third place and places in the UK it's
the pub and that's a big market now that
people are trying to fill I wonder if a
big part of that is is likes it a lack
of hobbies because people tend to
congregate around their hobbies and
create their own third place and be
interesting I wonder if that would play
a role I don't know enough about it but
I all I could say is I lament the the
lack of hobbies because they'd played
such a great role in bringing me joy as
a kid and the beauty was you were self
entertaining that's true see that hobby
so you can't say I don't think you could
say watching TV you can't say that's a
hobby because you're doing nothing right
you have to do something for it to be a
hobby well depends on what people are
watching on the Internet these days and
that is a destructive hobby as we would
call it with these young teenagers let
me ask you this because you discuss this
and it goes to the wider social issues
so you know you've been obviously an AM
radio for a long time and then there
have been people who've come and gone
largely been political who've had
sometimes bigger ratings and sometimes
less ratings than you but you've always
approached
for more of a cultural point of view at
least that's how I've seen it and that's
kind of the uprising that you're seeing
right now online you're seeing that on
YouTube you're seeing that on social
media if you look at the new
conservatives they're not interested in
micro policy but there is this wave of
preserving the idea of westernized
culture um and so I I don't say I say
this without a hint of meaning to be
insulting at all but as someone who is
older compared to these kids you know
white guy who they once champion as the
enemy of everything evil older white guy
patriarchy you kind of become the cool
kid because now people are wanting to
see the world through the lens with
which you've always presented it have
you seen that change in the last two
years yeah it's it way yours when you
are beating your drum for 40 years yes
and then people say oh I now hear it
right what's the first thing you do is
you thank God that you're still able to
beat the drum right at that that you're
not not only physically that I still
have this job and I have such access to
people yeah and more than ever because
the Prager University
that's got 400 million views this year
that's a lot of views yeah so uh but yes
there is a realization that at there's a
fundamental problem and that is an
assault on Western civilization and I
have you're right I've been doing about
that my whole life when the University
of Pennsylvania Ivy League school its
Department of English took down last
year its poster of Shakespeare yeah
because he was a white English male
white European male right you realize
it's over because the whole Western
civilization idea is based on what is
excellent yeah not what is your race
sure and we just talked about that
yesterday with them demanding in the
music festivals they're demanding less
light males well here's the thing there
were periods were that
the case of music festivals periods like
the Joni Mitchell's Stevie Nicks it just
isn't right now if you look at these big
music music vessels they don't really
want it they want to virtue signal and
claim they want it but I do think that
you are a particular messenger now I'm
not throwing anyone under the bus here
so please everyone out there hold your
emails but for example when I listen to
you when I was a much younger you would
run opposite the channel we had two
channels it was you or Rush is who I had
to decide to listen to as a young
teenager and um
brilliant radio host I'm not taking
anything away from him but as a younger
person it was far more interesting to me
to listen to the male female our the
happiness our discussing culture at
large then a senator who for example got
caught you know being bought off with a
corrupt bill that's not the kind of
voice that appeals to young people who
still believe in the same values that
you and I do someone like you is able to
communicate and it's just I don't think
you can fake that authenticity so I
wonder now do you have a bunch of just
young whippersnappers coming up and
wanting to take pictures I mean you're a
rock star on YouTube it's I have found a
fascinating development and that is when
I talk about non political subjects
mm-hmm the age average age of my caller
is in their 20s and 30s when I talk
about politics it's in the 60s
Wow that makes sense and you know what
and we have that almost exact kind of
analytical data that we would have
although when they tie together for
example we'll be talking about John
Oliver as we did in coal it's more so
taking on a cultural icon and falsehoods
but right away that's true and these
people they still want to see
westernized society thrive right they're
still on board that and I think a lot of
conservatives have dismissed them as
dumb because they're not involved in
their local congressional races they've
got bigger issues which is almost a
return to philosophy I actually have
more hope for this generation than I did
from my own the baby boomer really okay
I've made that case but explain it from
your point of view
oh very simple I knew we were I knew my
generation was lost I will never forget
I give you my word I'm a people who know
me long time
my radio I never exaggerate because I
really wanted to develop a reputation
for for credibility in graduate school I
was at Columbia University in New York
one day on that I really remember this
vividly all I remember walking around
about 116th and Broadway passing the bar
or whatever was and thinking oh my god I
am really alone I wasn't lonely but
because I had friends but I was alone
and believing in America that it was an
essentially good place in believing that
communism was evil in believing in the
judeo-christian value system uh it was
at Columbia University I I had one
kindred spirit one and I saw kids taken
over there by the way this notion kids
taking over the university leftist kids
this is this is as old as me man hey it
was happening when in the 70s when I was
at graduate school
yeah there's nothing new well you know
it's funny we had someone I think when
we were in Ireland recently talking with
them they they didn't believe me when I
said Generation Z is one of the most
conservative generations ever so I've
seen that they're mostly liberal it's in
the hall second I don't have the exact
numbers in front of me but if you take
for example the baby boomer generation
who've now become one of the more
conservative generations if you would
take them in their late teens or early
20s and 80% of them were liberal and now
you would have to take Generation Z and
only sixty percent of them would be
liberal it still means that a majority
of young people are liberal but not the
overwhelming majority that there that
existed with the baby boom generation
and I try to present it that way and
sometimes you can see the lights go on
with people but I agree with you and I
think the whole doom and gloom which
people present on a lot of talk radio
it's not something you peddle in and I I
genuinely believe there's a silver
lining with people younger than me by
the way it's a little younger than me
you know I'm going to turn thirty
relatively soon I'd say it's probably 22
and younger they seemed
he really it's that pendulum swinging
back against the radicals on campus and
um right and and there there is uh all
of this is news to me because I was
pessimistic I admit it right
well I'm not nearly as pessimistic now
partially oh well frankly in big park is
a pretty University because I see the
numbers and they're mostly young and
what they're saying is including high
school is a wait a minute we're just
curious to hear another side and then
they hear it just take take a you know
it and exempt any example but the number
of people and this is a political
economic thing which you would think
they're not interested in right but when
they you know everyone says minimum wage
minimum wage minimum wage well it turns
out that vast numbers of people get
fired from their jobs and and great
numbers of restaurants close up they no
longer in business because of these
compassionate minimum wage maybe it's
not so compassionate right and and a kid
is prepared to say that makes sense yeah
yet I think that's right and I also it's
also why it bothers me when people say
compassionate conservatism this is a
term that was coined conservatism is
already compassionate compassionate I
mean giving someone what they want when
they want it though it means truth and
that always but it's conceding too much
territorial and I'm a conservative but
I'm a compassionate concern right right
that's right yeah what was the thing but
so you are doing you're working on a
film with with Adam Carolla I want to
take your table do you have a title I
know it's about I know safe spaces look
at safe spaces and people should go to
the website and see the trailer and if
they're so inclined help us make it with
the donation because it's publicly
funded and Hollywood isn't going to make
it and but Adam and I are going to go
and we're going to uh with humor and
with seriousness exposed what's
happening on our college campuses in a
way that will really awaken vast numbers
of Americans including young people and
by the way I just and I'm not doing this
to patronize you the same exact issue
was in Canada there's no difference oh
no it's actually far worse in Canada
than its right that's
right yeah because there is no there is
no constitutional right to pretty much
speech which was just reaffirmed
yesterday which I'm happy about you know
it's funny that you mention this I was
working behind the scenes had already
sold the script the idea on a film very
similar to this it was partially
scripted partially documentary and we
shot some test footage at a couple
universities and one was University of
Michigan this is not a joke we sat down
there with the head of Afrocentric
lesbian studies and we sat down with an
animal telepathy who was teaching
students so we shot this scene where
this woman claimed that she was
communicating with a dead dog that we
made up and everyone had to treat this
as though it was a legitimate worldview
because she believes this idea of
reincarnation and when we looked through
the test footage just those years ago is
that no one's going to believe this this
is too far no one's going to this is too
absurd to be in the realm of reality and
it's white never got off the ground but
I think now everyone knows this is
mainstream on campus that reminds me of
one of Woody Allen's great lines in one
of his movies that he was majoring in
plant psychology what was this uh was
this some I'm trying to think of which
one was it
it wasn't Annie Hall was in Manhattan it
is probably Manhattan if it wasn't any
hole was probably Manhattan yeah but it
wasn't sleeper those are the three I
know all his films but those are the
three I know best sleeper is one of my
favorite films ever it was a girl how
could it not be I can't I don't start
really it's one of my favorite films
because it was the first one out in film
I was allowed to watch when I was young
and my father's like okay
I can you can watch this maybe around 11
years old and I just thought it was
funny when I went back and watched it
when I was older fantastic and Woody
Allen would probably hate the actual
commentary that it is on society today
because it would vindicate a much more
conservative point of view he probably
wouldn't like that but it's really not
okay well now you really started me on a
very interesting thing okay guys I
believe the most powerful film ever made
on behalf of God based ethics is Woody
Allen's film crimes and misdemeanors if
I told people this was made by
evangelical Christians they would have
said yet that makes sense Woody Allen
wrote it who is an atheist
right but he made the case in it for for
if there's no God nothing's wrong
right so powerfully no other film has
ever approached it it I considered one
of the 10 most important films ever made
crimes and misdemeanors
I wrote this Woody Allen wrote me a
letter this is like 30 years ago
and he said well I guess that's one way
of looking at it but I don't I don't
really think that's what I had in mind
but no no often artists art is greater
than the artist yeah that is absolutely
true and you do have to be able to
separate sometimes the art from the
artist otherwise you'd never see a Shawn
no I'm filming alright they exactly this
exists exactly right speaking of which
with fences were talking about culture
what happened to him I remember the Sean
Penn growing up who I said that man
deserves the award for I am Sam but this
was a stage in his career reset Awards
ceremonies were rigged they were fake
they were grant it was too it was
basically a masturbatory all
congratulate Ori sessions and he never
showed up
murdered for years Sean Penn will never
trust an award ceremony that's why he
lost for I am Sam and now he is mr.
award ceremony at the world it will give
credit to Woody Allen he doesn't go
that's true that chance wouldn't that's
Woody Allen's view of the ceremonies
yeah
also um probably because he's wanted for
crimes against humanity oh it's so
unfortunately nosey bump into people
yeah now worth it okay so speaking puts
another point that you make what we're
talking about society and a lot of young
people are making this now their fault
that they're falling into this idea that
okay their understanding feminism for
the fraud that it is you've made the
point that feminism ironically isn't
feminine whatsoever that it's actually
anti feminine and I always thought that
was interesting so I want you the master
to explain it to people watching well
from the beginning I said feminism is a
misnomer it doesn't celebrate the
feminine it celebrates the masculine
men have sex with it with no emotion and
can go from body to body and have a
great time well so can we women which
was just a prescription for depression
in a lot of young women that's why so
many more are depressed in the college
era or at the college age they have
bought this nonsense your sexuality is
just like male sexuality they've acted
on it but if they're in turns out their
sexuality is not like male sexuality
it's not better not worse it's just
different so if that was a clear
prescription of what's B like meant
another one men define themselves by
their work we women will define
ourselves by our work so you're crazy if
you think the most important thing you
could do is be a mother and wife and
make a home you're crazy you will get
your joy from sales degree or that's
where your meaning in life will come
from by the way for a male in sales it
is perfectly true
much of his we are we men we are what we
do whether we like it or not that is the
way we think sure because I think male
and female is different but
complementary yes well that's what you
know that there's a biblical world you
see we've often referred to it in the
church as complementarianism let me ask
you this you know I view it that way
like you said men will take pride in
sales or for example a big part of what
defines me outside of obviously my faith
my relationships is is my work a big
component to that is because work is how
you provide for your woman for your
family which is central to mathematical
inity and that's a big part of identity
and it's not for a woman do you think
that plays a big role yes that's that's
exactly right and then look how do I
know I know this because I like you how
to eyes understanding not from me from
something wise called the Bible I know
it's mocked today because everything it
stands for the left doesn't stand for so
there's a real conflict in civilization
okay fine but I knew it later from calls
from women on to my radio show
and they would say I would say so let me
ask you now that you are 40 years old 50
years old how do you did if you bought
feminism in college are you happy you
did and caller after caller said I was
sold a bill of goods
I now am a very high CEO but you know
what it pales in comparison to coming
home to a husband and children yeah and
I made it I'm just a big mistake well
you know that that is something and I
was actually going to say to oh it goes
with your point first no no go ahead I
my thing was it's funny how we talked
about this morning it's a it's a
feminism as a celebration really of
masculinity but somehow they figure it
out to vilify the premise of men is
immediately vilified persons this
weekend over Father's Day University of
Michigan Carol studies saying low
testosterone may actually make you a
better father and it just comes as the
premises yeah masculinity let's remove
what makes a male your male that's all
going to be like women yeah and also
it's like it's where the Metro ethics
well that the point here is their real
agenda is to feminized men and
masculinize women yeah yeah that's their
real agenda they don't want differences
right it bothers them because here is
this took me decades to figure out
leftism is at war with reality yeah it's
too big life is too messy
let's undo it and in that ironic because
they always like to claim the territory
of nuance right you right litter it as
black and white we through the nuance
but they are right reality just at some
point is it on the thing or how about
this we're we're anti science if we
merely say yes the world is getting
warmer but we don't know fully why and
we don't necessarily think we'll become
extinct in 25 or 30 years right we're
anti science but if you say a person who
has a vagina a uterus ovaries eggs to a
two X chromosomes
and breasts and produces milk is not a
woman
that's not anti-science no I know it
we've made when this show so I'm sure in
large parts are being influenced by you
um you know what it's funny that you you
bring that up I will say this as far as
giving you more hope we see a lot of
young people who are atheists who watch
our show for example we have convert
Crowder week sorry my dog it has to go
out to the best and this is the wonder
of new media isn't here in the studio we
have convert Crowder week because I said
I was at an Irish Catholic wedding and
people are trying to convert me to
Catholicism and I said if people want to
present the case as to why it's the one
true church I will welcome it we can
have this discussion people most excited
about it are atheists only like New
Atheism in the era sort of of Dawkins
less so Hitchens and then Sam Harris a
lot of them have turned on it and said
well you know what I don't necessarily
believe in God but they call themselves
Christian sympathetic because they do
see judeo-christian values as the
fulcrum of Western society so I will say
that is changing at a very rapid rate
just in the last year and a half people
who aren't even girls well that that's
great to hear I hope they'll see our
videos for example my videos on the Ten
Commandments because even if you're an
atheist at least see why that's the
central moral document of humanity yeah
I agree with you and let me ask you so I
okay there's no other way to approach it
did you read about I'm sorry I'm not
trying to be crass here BuzzFeed
speaking of women feminism the women who
painted with their their menstruation
blood have you seen this oh this is
another gift of the left scatological
art okay urine fecal matter menstrual
blood and I'm not putting menstrual
blood with those other two things but
what if the body excretes it they make
art out of it it this is what the
talent-free do at some point you start
505 cell just begging for more Jackson
Pollock paintings because god that's
right at least bleeding
that's kind of like was actually with
music now with this alternative rock I'm
going God just bring me back Pink
Floyd's 40 minutes of you an animal
sounds okay you know you will love this
today on my show I played a few minutes
of a new piece of music classical music
that's what I meant I got conduct
orchestras periodically so I followed
this stuff what the left is done to art
is like what they did about what they've
done to music is what they've done to
art and it's become nonsense yeah a guy
wrote a three-and-a-half-hour piece just
using one note a d real people yes it
and how do I know it was seriously
reviewed in the New York Times Wow wow
that is how if you can't when we get off
there have wonder people send that over
if you can't I would love to see what I
love to talk about on them you know no
no all right you send me an email and I
will be mail back to you the article
that sounds fantastic and it's got a
it's got a sound sample with it so you
could play it for your listeners yeah
what really bothers me about that and
then I want to get back to the masculine
anything because I do I do it important
point I want to ask you about what
really bothers me about that is the same
thing that bothers me about sports for
example Gerald Morgan is often on the
show in that chair he went to Notre Dame
he was the first pick to go to Notre
Dame blew his knee out never got to play
football we probably don't know who the
best athletes were of all time because
they didn't make it through the ringer
they're probably some unbelievable
athletes who just blew a knee out blew
an ankle out I knew a guy to compare it
to art there was a guy in the Montreal
subway system this is true just like you
I'm not exaggerating you've heard me
talk about this on the show several
times three flutes one in each nostril
one in his mouth and he played the
entire Star Wars theme song alright well
that that is great but you'll never know
about him right because someone's there
with their period blood what bothers me
that they bump the raht for the guy that
subway I do want to know I wish you had
a picture though how do you get a flute
up your nose all that maybe was that I
would aside what me with vite maybe
these were Piccolo's well piccolo is
possible maybe they are piccolo
piccolo Piccolo's in a flute and by the
way that same guy then put
two sticks here and did the tympani yes
yes see brother probably could I
wouldn't put it past him with a guy
whose spoons outside of oval leaves that
was our Macy's good tip don't go this
guy this guy has a gift and no one will
ever know alright anyway going back to
the feminism issue here's one thing
you've talked about a lot and I think is
important people to know at the same
time as we're talking about
imbuing women with these fundamental
human rights like abortion and free
birth control now right all of these are
women's rights they depth there
definitely is a movement to simply strip
men of basic biological functions which
have served as rights for example man
spreading with a big video coming out on
that tomorrow that's been banned in
Madrid it's where men sit slightly wider
we will
yes been banned in Madrid in Madrid and
there's a push to ban it elsewhere we
actually went on it people will see this
tomorrow
specifically on on the public transit
medical and public transportation we
asked women we offered them a $20 gift
card to take part in the experiment we
said okay look how you're sitting now we
want you to put on this apparatus and
all it was was a jockstrap
which they put on outside of their pants
so would be nowhere near as
uncomfortable of having a sexual organ
between your legs they sat down and
every single one of them man spread and
said I get it now this really wouldn't
be comfortable to close my legs and it's
a law in a place like Madrid and then
you have the cultural ramifications of
practices you've talked about this like
smoking cigars pipes the things that men
have naturally enjoyed for a long time
these are being stripped away eliminated
as like you said even hobbies let alone
rights while we're adding new
non-existent rights to the feminine that
seems to be something that has really
turned off a lot of young males
including even some young formerly
feminists well it's good to hear because
the the I have said often I feel
sympathy for this generation there they
are the object of an experiment yeah for
example the number of teachers who will
no longer call an elementary school will
no longer call their students boys and
girls they're told to the in Charlotte
North Carolina they were given and
River do not refer to your students as
boys and girls just as students because
they don't want to impose a gender
identity on a ten-year-old yeah I
actually would take the other view where
if you allow your ten-year-old to go
through a sex change operation or any
kind of hormone replacement therapy you
should be locked away for child that's
right that's correct we are really in
sync that's exactly right
well speaking of that we've made I don't
know if you've talked about this on your
show but just as far as science you know
you know the whole organic food trend
I'm sure your way obviously you're in
California and I'm sure you're aware of
you know bpa-free you see that term
everywhere right means this is safe
plastic don't put this in the microwave
well the reason for that is because
these chemicals act as what they call
xenoestrogens in the body in other words
they can raise estrogen to a level that
can actually in a male specifically be
toxic so we use organic food to avoid
the pesticides what image they all say
we're I'm saying the same thing you stay
away from soy don't put lavender on your
nipples these are rules that you live by
but then when injected directly into
your ass however we're supposed to
believe that a certain replacement
therapy and the male anatomy is
consequence-free it's something I've
never had explained to me other than I'm
a hate speaker well other than those who
feel that they're women who would get
this no one
yeah no male would oh I see you're
saying that even those there would be
some health consequence yes absolutely I
mean a big part of your fitness industry
in the organic food is to avoid you know
basically estrogen mimickers that's what
they are in the body specifically males
they talk about this GMO it specifically
goes back time and time again to you
know men have higher estrogen levels and
this increases cancer you know well yeah
you've already I mean you're
sterilization to that point yes yes
exactly but then they abandon this ship
when it comes to men saying they want to
be a woman and they want to inject
estrogen they say well you know what the
science of an in yet we don't know if
it's bad for them well the whole thing
is is anti science and as I said earlier
you have every single physical
characteristic of a female but if you
say you're a male you're male now
you say to me look I am physiologically
a female I really have that what we call
gender dysphoria I identify as a man I
will dress as a man I will do whatever I
can to look like a man please call me
Bill it's all cool no no I'm not being
chemical King at all I will call you
Bill
sure I will honor it the issue to me is
not compassion for the individual it's
the war on the belief that there is male
and female that's what is so dangerous
and by the way I'll tell you where it
began it began with same-sex marriage
that same-sex marriage the argument was
to two arguments one the gender of your
spouse is irrelevant marriage is
marriage gender is irrelevant - it
doesn't matter if a child has a mother
and father two fathers two mothers is
just as good because there's no
difference between the sexes once those
were accepted as arguments this is
inevitable if there's no difference then
you are what you want to be yeah and you
know what I will say this you you
probably don't you had a caller on your
show and I thought that this central
premise that you're discussing right now
is the single easiest refutation of
comparing integrated marriage racially
mixed marriage versus same-sex marriage
and I don't know if you remember this
but a caller said well what's the
difference then if you're saying you
know did what would you have had a
problem with black and white women
getting married black men and white
women and I don't know I don't to put
you in a spot do you remember how you
answered yes go yeah as I said there is
no difference between a black and a
white but there were great differences
between a man and a woman yes it's quite
simple you know it is it's quite simple
you worded it in a way that stuck with
me
I hate knots in it you it's not as good
now but every word that you said I I
don't believe that there's anything a
white mother can provide for a child
that a black mother can't but I
certainly believe that there in your
mother can provide that is my better
answer
haha I don't know better but it stuck
with me because I remember providing
that answer to teachers in college and
they
that you're getting a nap so just not be
you by the way I'm just curious where do
you hear my show um well now we're just
here to online I haven't listened to
radio in a long time
are you hearing online yeah back then
this is when my family lived in Dallas
and I think you were a case guy and
followed by Michael Burnett read that's
correct
okay yeah no no actually we visited
Dallas and then I was in Montreal and I
would listen to case guy online because
I was the only station I did we didn't
get conservative radio in Montreal right
you can get my show I'm a lot of
Canadian listeners but they're like this
underground movement yeah in Canada
III was stunned when you had a
conservative Prime Minister I was
stunned I know Canada pretty well right
it was an aberration yes and he was
fantastic by the way one of the most
consistent prime ministers we've had in
Harper Harper was your Reagan I said
that all the time yeah he really was he
really was and we knew people who would
go just a movie theater and they'd run
into him all the time just the nicest
guy okay mr. Prager even enough of your
time let me ask you this final closing
thought if you are to pass the torch
because now you have this this massive
audience and you do have the ear of a
lot of young people we've talked about
masculine and feminine and kind of
cultural Western civilization there's
one takeaway that you want younger
people people listening to this show to
take away as far as what is most
important for them to learn and
understand to take that torch from your
generation and make sure that it's not
lost as they pass it on it's I have in
my mind I'm racing through what really
what idea what I like to leave most I
think in the final analysis I would if
this may not be the most important but
there is none that is more important
okay people are not basically good and
the most important task of a society is
to figure out how to make people good
the left believes people are good they
inherited the French Revolution I
inherited the Bible and the American
Revolution which was based on the Bible
they know we're not basically good I'm
not saying we're basically evil but
we're not basic
be good and therefore unlike the unlike
the left
I don't blame rape and murder on poverty
or racism I blame it on the murderer or
the rapist and how do you make good
people should preoccupy us I think
that's a good one to pick even if as you
said you're not sure if it's the most
important idea but you're no more
hardened it's time yes it's tied up
there with collecting baseball cards but
I will say that you talked about that
last time and that is what stuck with a
lot of people so I'm glad to hear you
reiterated at dennis prager
on twitter dennis prager comp Reger
university please go support if you want
to his film with Adam Carolla's being
crowdfunded no safe spaces mr. Prager
thank you so much for taking the time we
hope to have you back again and again as
long as you're able to I want to come
back again and again here is the light
oh stop it you're going to make me blush
we'll see you all tomorrow with the
manspreading video and as soon as we
ship for something mr. preggers send me
that that's a team
[Music]